[Musique]
une après midi de gala poissy le
footballeur blaise matuidi champion du
monde avec l'équipe de france cet été en
russie est venue inaugurer un mini stade
flambant neuf qui portera son nom dans
le quartier de la coudraie c'est un
endroit de
avoir justement ce
on
grand est
et
l'idée de donner le nom de blaise
matuidi à ce mini stade a été lancé par
le maire de la commune qu'un l'olive
l'élu a rencontré l'ancien joueur du psg
le 21 juin dernier après le match de la
coupe du monde france pérou et lui a
proposé de participer au projet blaise
est un champion du monde exceptionnelle
c'est aussi un joueur exceptionnel
l'exemplarité sur le terrain et en
dehors du terrain on vient encore de le
constater je crois que c'était vraiment
bien un exemple à trouver et je suis
ravi parce qu'on est à la veille de la
rentrée scolaire
regardez ces gamins je crois que c'est
un dernier cadeau de vacances comme
dernier cadeau de vacances certains ont
pu obtenir un autographe pour
immortaliser l'instant
ici ici à je suis content j'ai bien
dormir ce soir mardi c'est ma vie au
total plus de mille personnes ont pu
approcher le footballeur le soleil de
poids s'il a bien accueilli et on est
vraiment contents on est fiers de
l'accueillir ici
voilà c'est vraiment sympathique de ses
parents blaise matuidi en a également
profité pour remettre au quartier de la
coudraie le fameux maillot de l'équipe
de france floqué des deux étoiles
les supporteurs sont eux repartis avec
des étoiles plein les yeux